bonsoir nous sommes le vendredi 29 avril
et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition
de votre journal de fin de semaine au
cours de la prochaine demi heures visite
des nouveautés du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'open de
france débute le 30 juin
le green est déjà prêt les changements
profiteront aussi aux compétiteurs lors
du rendez vous international de la ryder
cup en 2018 est des jeunes de l'étoile
sportive de trappes était à bordeaux
cette semaine pour visiter le musée
national de la sécurité sociale un
déplacement qui peut sembler insolite
mais qui a surtout été l'occasion de
mieux leur expliquer les valeurs du
collectif et de la solidarité et puis
comme chaque vendredi le zapping de
l'information locale depuis lundi les
principaux sujets développés par la
rédaction
entre les déplacements des ténors
politiques dans les yvelines le portrait
d'un marathonien de 61 ans qui ne manque
pas de souffle
le premier mais tombera un dimanche
cette année mais cela reste malgré tout
la fête du travail célébrée depuis la
fin du 19e siècle en hommage au combat
du mouvement ouvrier
elle est aussi l'occasion pour le parti
communiste français de se mobiliser pour
vendre le fameux muguet censé marquer le
retour des beaux jours les différentes
sections sont donc en pleine préparation
mais quel ennemi d'euros patrick jacques
de dixmude à 48 heures de la fête du
travail la maison des communistes située
à trappes avenue carlo accélère pour
boucler ses livraisons de muguet la
structure doit répartir plus de 3400
brun dans l'ensemble du département
c'est un travail important en a - faut
déjà contacté des producteurs surtout en
période de pénurie de muguet comme on a
cette année avec le climat c'est pas si
facile que ça ensuite on regarde les
produits comprend les transmet à nos
sections qui nous passent les commandes
et nous on passe une commande globale
la fête du 1er mai permet au parti
communiste français de récolter près de
600000 euros dans l'hexagone
mais pour la structure cette dette est
avant tout politique après la vente du
muguet le matin dans les yvelines la
journée se poursuivra par une magnifique
a sion dans les rues de paris l'après
midi la vente du muguet c'est un côté
symbolique mais c'est aussi un petit peu
une excuse c'est un moment où sur
l'ensemble du territoire du département
on aura des communistes partout qu'ils
vont vendre le muguet ce qui est comme
une initiative financière qui n'est pas
négligeable pour pour les finances de
notre fédération mais c'est aussi un
moment des changes politique de dialogue
de discussion c'est la fête des
travailleurs là où le premier
revendications des huit heures par jour
de travail a eu lieu
c'est un grand rassemblement de tous les
travailleurs une solidarité
internationale également cette année
dans les rues de paris le parti
communiste français le front de gauche
présenteront leur questionnaire baptisé
que demande le peuple
le document a pour but d'analyser les
principaux sujets d'inquiétude des
français
des graffitis pour décorer la ville
l'initiative a été lancée à la verrière
par l'association prévert en partenariat
avec l'artiste soleil erdf dessine ta
ville c'est le nom du projet qui permet
à plusieurs jeunes de la ville est de
laisser libre cours à leur âme
artistique sur deux transformateurs nous
vous en parlions en mars déjà lors d'un
reportage sur le premier d'entre eux
c'était au bois de l'étang mercredi 27
avril c'était au tour de celui d'orly
parc de profiter de cette mise en beauté
écouter la maire de la commune elle est
au micro de camille lambert
il ya déjà deux fresques qui sont très
différentes l'une de l'autre
donc c'est bien et c'est
l'imagination qui prend le dessus et
enfin visiblement les jeunes qu'on a là
sont heureux
d'avoir fait de montrer et sont fiers et
ça ça compte beaucoup
il y en avait 2 prévu pour l'instant et
puis vu vu que ça se passe très très
bien on va voir quelle quelle autre
partenariat on peut faire dans le temps
toujours dans la même veine on a des
artistes qui commencent à y prendre goût
donc il faut continuer et il est temps
de passer à l'entretien de ce journal
paul armitage bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes le directeur du golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le golfe
qui vient de faire peau neuve en tout
cas son parcours celui de l'arc balade
battre aux pardons on va en parler plus
en détail dans un instant on regarde
tout d'abord ce reportage signé michael
et demie d'or
l'albatros va rouvrir ses portes au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
parcours qui accueille tous les ans
l'open de france a été totalement
relooké au vu de la ryder cup 2018 sans
trop de personnes ont travaillé sur
cette rénovation pour le neuf mois
c'était problème de l' aider les pauvres
challenge coordonner toutes ces
personnes tous été repris c'est dingue
entre guillemets un petit espace
commencé et pour l'essayer les élèves
d'obtenir la la la la meilleure
efficacité pour le chantier les clients
n'ont pas pu accéder au green s'est ré
ouverture était donc attendue depuis
plusieurs semaines
c'est vrai ça pas comme un lien mais
quand on branche avril albatros et oui
oui il y a
nos clients sont arrivés des rayons
halal va être cédée tester les et c'est
pas cool ces nouvelles versions des
départs coup les principaux changements
de cet albatros 2.0 concerne les trous
numéro 11 et 16
les deux parcours ont été totalement
remodelé pour les rendre plus esthétique
pour le 11 un lac a été créé les
difficultés ont également été modifiées
mois pour les tonnelles et trouve
quelqu'un pour les usa matin ça va être
plus simple et ça va on va s'amuser sur
la plus amusante
on a fait les soldes et s'approche et
qu'est ce que ça va être moins
compliquée pour les joueurs amateurs et
mais par contre pour les yeux un
professionnel et il y a il y a pas mal
d'obstacles quelques bons qu'ils vont
faire la tâche est difficile on domine
18 de l'open de france pour fêter ses
traits ouverture le golf national
organise un concours de précision ce
samedi 30 avril de 11h à 18h sur le trou
numéro un pour la remise ce sera plus
simple pour les amateurs vers est
d'accord franchement je suis d'accord
avec alejandro sûr beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de choses mais peut-être pas là
je pense pas parce que ces changements
n'étaient pas uniquement esthétique y
aura aussi un changement sur les
conditions de jeu l'objectif on va s'y
attendait après mais c'est de préparer
la ryder cup s'en va y venir mais mais
déjà là ça change véritablement les
conditions de jeu les modifications oui
oui je pense que le golfeur qui connaît
bien l'albatros
il va voir quelques différences eelv a
remarqué une différence au niveau 2
de l'environnement la nature on a dû
évacuer pas mal de puissants de choses
comme ça parce que recevoir dans deux
ans et demi soixante dix mille personnes
par jour sur le site
il faut de l'espace et donc on va
redonner de l'espace
on travaille avec avec plusieurs
institutions des consultants et le
muséum d'histoire naturelle pour pouvoir
redonner cette nature après l'événement
quand comment comment vous travaillez
justement est ce qu'il ya des cahiers
des charges imposé pour la ryder cup
oui un contre un qui fait presque trois
cents pages déjà entre eux et entre la
fédération française de golf et les
commandeurs les détenteurs de droits de
la ryder cup qui l european tour le
corps professionnels européens
donc oui on travaille seul ans
nos engagements les engagements pour
avoir l'obtenir la ryder cup et ce
contrat parce que cette ryder cup
justement on va s'y attarder c'est une
compétition entre les meilleurs
européens et puis les meilleurs
américains compétition qui existe depuis
et ce sera la première ville en france
absolument sera la première région
particulière gisement la deuxième fois
que ça quitte les îles britanniques ya
une pression particulière sur vos
épaules oui tous tous les jours je pense
mais c'est une bonne pression
une bonne pression comme on vous l'a
elle l'appréhender justement cette ryder
que vous vous dites on sera dans les
clous tout est prêt là on le voit le
parcours a été modifié
alors là il ya aucun il n'y a aucun
doute parce que si on n'est pas preuve
là ce serait vraiment l'échec donc non
sera on sera prêt mais en attendant on
vide y est on veut pas passer le temps
trop rapidement et espérer être là
aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
chemin il ya beaucoup de choses à
organiser ce qui est sécuritaire
transport etc
mais ces travaux était une étape hyper
importante
ça s'est bien passé dans les temps dans
les budgets donc on a un bon espoir
d'organiser peut-être le meilleur ryder
cup qui est venu le budget justement sur
les modifier des travaux 7,7 millions
dont 7 millions juste pour le parcours
sur le parcours parce qu'il n'ya pas que
ça il ya aussi des modifications pour
accueillir le public pour la
restauration pour le logement
tout ça c'est des choses aussi que vous
allez gérer oui alors les organisateurs
qui paye
évidemment
tout ça nous nos engagements c'était cet
essai coup c'est ses coûts de
modifications en fait nos obligations
lors de l'événement s'arrête presque à
la porte on est chez nous mais pendant
l'événement un peu moins parce que la
ryder cup c'est tout de même
l'équivalent de la coupe du monde de
football pour les jeunes connaissent pas
encore le golf alors justement autour de
tout ça il ya beaucoup de monde qui va
se déplacer pour venir assister est ce
que vous sentez déjà un engouement ne
serait ce qu'au près des yvelinois des
saint quentinois parce que l'enjeu
nouvelle a aussi lancé la première fois
que ça se jouera en france c'est de
faire venir des licenciés ensuite alors
bon il ya l'ouverture la réouverture pré
ouverture de la réouverture de
l'albatros demain donc on est sollicité
par les médias par certaines mais c'est
tous les jours il y à une sollicitation
que ce soit pour la presse que ce soit
localement
parce qu'il ya des clubs maintenant
qu'ils se montrent sky golf 2018 par
exemple si tu y golf 2018 est une
association qui a été monté dans avec
l'objectif de communiquer dans la ville
la nouvelle ville auprès des entreprises
et des gens que cet événement va avoir
lieu il faut en profiter
pourquoi il faut en profiter parce que
pendant presque six - il va y avoir 300
personnes qui vont travailler sur le
montage de l'événement ce sera des
britanniques sera des français sera des
entreprises locales
mais ce sont des gens qui vont vouloir
aller au restaurant qui vont vouloir se
coiffer qui vont vouloir consommer dans
notre révérence donc il ya des retombées
économiques qui vont venir il faut le
faire savoir
aujourd'hui là c'est la réouverture là
le public va pouvoir découvrir tout ça
dès ce week end comment ça va
s'organiser justement ces découvertes
tout à fait alors comme dans le
reportage demain en fait de 10 heures
18 heures on a invité tous les licenciés
de golf parce que dans le modèle
économique de la ryder cup
on prélève 3 euros par an sur la licence
qui vend dans un compte uniquement pour
nous aider à financer l'avs ryder cup
donc ses licenciés quelques parcs et qui
paye pendant une dizaine d'années cette
épreuve où la venue de cette épreuve
donc pour les remercier on les a invités
en attend 1200 personnes
ce qui est formidable qui sont inscrits
plus ceux qui vont se pointer sans
s'inscrire
donc pour fêter ça on a un dj on essaye
de serre faire ça un peu fun un peu un
peu ça reste à festi voilà il ya
que animations il ya des shows d un dj
appuiera la ryder cup 1 ça sera en 2018
c'est un peu tôt encore pour faire le
point sur les chances françaises
oui c'est un peu tôt sachant que
il y a de fortes chances que nous ayons
un français dans la ryder cup cette
année déjà parce que on en a un qui est
déjà parti bien parti c'est victor
dubuisson pour 2016 parce que ça se joue
aux etats unis cette fois tous les deux
ans est lente en alternance pour 2018 je
sais qu'ils vont se battre pour y être
et d'ici là une fois qu'on met de côté
cette ryder cup est encore le temps où
on y reviendra bien sûr dans les
prochains mois voire les prochaines
années mais il ya l'open de france elle
a loupé mon lit france ça commencera à
partir du 30 juin
il ya aussi tout est prêt alors oui
comme vous avez vu on attend un peu de
chaleur pour pour que le parcours
vraiment
le gazon la nature se réveille
complètement parce que ces derniers
jours à saint quentin en yvelines on a
eu un petit peu froid donc la nature
s'est rendormi un peu dans will open
s'annonce le centième édition
merveilleusement bien en annoncer bien
sûr la venue de deux euros remy
qu'heureux qui est qui est un plus
énorme ce numéro trois mondial c'est le
meilleur européen
vous êtes numéro un européen qui existe
c'est un barnum qui va venir avec lui
des médias mondiaux qui vont vouloir le
suivre ça on n'a pas l'habitude
nécessairement d'avoir tout une suivi
médiatique comme ça de
il a twitté sur son compte twitter
lui-même sa venue à paris
101 euros de ce qu'on appelle pur in the
money c'est à dire qu'on le paye pas
pour venir il vient pour pour faire
honneur à l'open de france parcourt de
la ryder cup et ses accès et en a
effectivement des retombées médiatiques
monstrueux déjà donc c'est bon pour la
naissance pour l'open oui oui tout à
fait tout à fait en laye fait ces
dernières années
oui absolument je pense que l'open déjà
c'est le tournoi le plus ancien du vieux
continent
donc l'european tour et retombe ans un
peu cette fidélité en nous aidant à voir
quelqu'un comme mcilroy
merci paul armitage ryder cup donc en
2018 à partir du 30 juin la de cette
année ce sera le traditionnel open
annuel open golf national qui ouvre ses
portes dès ce week-end avec un concours
de précision
ce sera entre 11 heures et 18 heures ça
sur le trou numéro 11 exactement on se
bouge
voilà très précis on aurait découvert ce
nouveau parcours de l'albatros merci
merci à passer sur ce plateau
nous poursuivons ce journal est cette
semaine cette vingtaine de jeunes de
l'étoile sportive de trappes qui ont
décidé de participer à un voyage pour le
moins originale sous l'initiative de
mustapha larbaoui le président du club
également président de l'association
pharma citoyens ce sont des enfants de 9
à 11 ans qui ont fait l'aller retour
dans la journée entre ap et bordeaux
pour visiter le musée national de la
sécurité sociale l'objectif apprendre
les valeurs du collectif et la
solidarité également nous les avons
suivis camille lambert
si la plupart des enfants profitent
encore de leur lit en vacances c'est 23
jeunes du club de foot de l'étoile
sportive de trappes eux sont bien
matinaux mardi 26 avril il s'apprête à
embarquer pour six heures de bus
destination le musée national de la
sécurité sociale le rapport entre la
sécu elle football l'homme aux simples
s'appelle le collectif 6 heures du matin
départ pour lormont à côté de bordeaux
un périple initié pour la première fois
dans le cadre de l'association pharma
citoyens avec pour objectif transmettre
aux jeunes les valeurs de la solidarité
et s'il ya quelque chose qui symbolise
bien le collectif
le collectif national c'est bien la
sécurité sociale et je voulais qu'on
leur rende hommage et que les enfants
comprennent ce que c'est qu'un collectif
dans le jeu mais également un collectif
au sein de la nation au sein de la
république près de 600 kilomètres plus
tard arrivée au château des lauriers en
gironde pour le déjeuner résidence de la
famille gradis au 19e siècle le bâtiment
héberge le musée national de l'assurance
maladie depuis 27 ans et c'est la
maîtresse de maison elle même qui vient
accueillir les visiteurs venus de loin
chanter marin poilu au messager du roi
mari anthony font vivre ses personnages
sous les yeux des enfants
maintenant on prend un plaisir énorme
parce qu'il ya une valeur qui magnifique
qui les promus dans cette visite la
solidarité chirurgien lady du roi henri
iv en 1604 qui actait pour la première
fois un chirurgien pour les mineurs ou
encore la mise en place d'un régime de
protection sociale pour les marins par
aliénor d'aquitaine
une dizaine de saynètes imaginées depuis
deux ans pour apprendre aux jeunes les
étapes importantes de la création de la
sécurité sociale en 1945 il faut pouvoir
faire des bonds dans le temps et surtout
se remet dans des ambiances
c'est bien de parler d'une histoire de
se remettre dans un contexte historique
mais on a le matériel on a des pièces de
collection et dans cette pièce en
particulier c'est qu'on a du matériel
d'origine qui a été utilisé à partir des
années 50 entre les années 50 et 70 dans
les centres de paiement des caisses de
sécurité sociale
monsieur bonjour rodrigo bien travailler
deux heures de visite et c'est déjà
l'heure de rentrer les jeunes trappistes
font le point sur leurs connaissances
certaines personnes qui rend pour
sceller
quant aux machines me sens mieux et va
supporter on doit payer votre rouge et
eux ils remboursent par exemple et 15
euros
c'est l'euro qui a dit qu'ils allaient
en place au début c'étaient des idiots
et des anges est collé
les mineurs va dès qu'on a des problèmes
au moins ya des gens qui peuvent souris
verte ou une devise a même été créé
durant le voyage pour résumer simplement
le principe
le collectif s'est effectivement ne pas
jouer seul comptait sur son voisin et
faire en sorte que son voisin soit un
allié également dans l'est dans les bas
dans les difficultés de la vie et en
fait spontanément ils m'ont dit bah
quand est-ce qu'on reparle quand est-ce
qu'on fait quelque chose c'est avec des
souvenirs plein la tête que les enfants
retrouvent leurs parents un peu à
contrecoeur de voir leur périple se
termine et face au succès de cette
première initiative le club de l'étoile
sportive de trappes prévoit déjà
d'autres destinations comme chaque
vendredi nous passons maintenant à
l'essentiel de la semaine le zapping des
sujets développés dans ce journal depuis
lundi formation et innovation deux mots
clés de la venue de gérard larcher
président du sénat boidin 6 lundi 25
avril
au programme visite de deux des 70
entreprises de la zone arcisienne
delacroix bonnet première étape la
plateforme de service après vente du
groupe ou 8,6 implantée sur le site
depuis 2012 c'est un bassin où les
chiffres de l'emploi sont plutôt bons
ils font rêver
dans le reste du pays c'est en même
temps on le voit bien une période qui
n'est pas facile débattre autour des
grands enjeux économiques de demain
c'était l'objectif de cette réunion
publique organisée à l'hôtel de ville de
mort pas parmi les thématiques abordées
la formation professionnelle les
nouvelles croissances et le revenu
universel le vieux modèle social
français est usée jusqu'à la corde
dans moins de dix ans pourra plus payer
les retraites il donc il faut faire
quelque chose
donc il faut éradiquer la pauvreté il
faut lutter contre le chômage
un important carambolage impliquant deux
poids lourds et six véhicules s'est
produit aujourd'hui vers 13 heures sur
l'autoroute a13 à hauteur des mureaux en
direction de paris pour une raison
encore inconnue le poids loi a traversé
le terre-plein central et percuté les
six véhicules deux blessés graves ont
été évacués en hélicoptère vers des
hôpitaux et neuf personnes sont
impliquées une légèrement blessé
l'association prévention routière se
mobilisent contre la mortalité infantile
sur les routes
la structure vient de lancer un
manifeste aux lignes autour du thème 0
enfants tués sur les routes cette
opération pour objectif d'enrayer un
phénomène qui tue chaque fois sept
enfants france un bilan inchangé depuis
dix ans
la première fonction de ce lieu l'un va
être un lieu d'activités culturelles et
ald activités cultuelles aussi pour une
raison très simple parce que là où vous
avez du culte vous avez un local qui est
ouvert pratiquement toute la semaine
donc plus accessible et donc on peut
être plus réactif en cas de problème
quand il faut éventuellement faire
quelque chose' la vie vis-à-vis de nos
jeunes enfin membres du conseil des
jeunes de la ville de caudry nietzsche
et en république tchèque ont été
accueillis par leurs homologues
trappistes de ville jumelle rassembler
autour du programme erasmus plus c'est
juste que c'était tchèque et nous on est
français mais on on échange nos projets
tels que je laisse kosice scène j'ai
toujours voulu venir en france et voir
paris alors c'est une très bonne
occasion d'être là et de se faire des
ennemis en plus il y en a qui parlent
anglais mais la plupart du temps on ne
sait pas jusqu'à 2000
10 gt comme les 7 milliards
du 1 du main qui pensaient que le
marathon c'est c'est pas pour eux c'est
pour déjà exceptionnel j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir été affecté à chicago consul
général adjoint de france et le marathon
de chicago est extrêmement populaire
d'un coin d'un deux ans j'ai applaudi le
coureur et puis la troisième année j'ai
décidé de me faire applaudir par les
autres très vite sidy diallo est devenu
accro au marathon le sportif en totalise
48 sur l'année 2013 et réalise son
meilleur temps 2012 au marathon de
berlin en allemagne en 3 heures 14
minutes et 13 secondes et après ce
résumé de la semaine retour de notre
séquence regard de jeunes sur
l'actualité comment les plus jeunes
perçoivent l'information locale et
nationale les réponses des collégiens
des saules à guyancourt et du collège de
giacometti aussi à montigny le
bretonneux
yao bo qui a été dans une salle de
classe qui a aidé les élèves il ya un
robot qui a battu fin du mois aux échecs
c'est l'intelligence des hommes qui est
dans un robot c'est c'est soit s'est
améliorée soit c'est pour remplacer les
hommes les robots 6e sont que des
machines est ici pas vu qu'on pas le
compas qui sont nés avec un cerveau non
enfin sinon que les encres et là
l'intelligence artificielle a beaucoup
évolué et le jour elle dépassera alors
on sait pas ce qui peut arriver quoi si
un jour elle est dotée de conscience ça
allait être chaud pour nous le scanner
rebours on l'a fabriqué et fermons notre
corps le robot est logiquement quelqu'un
il ya quelque chose dans le cerveau
ce qui logiquement ebay l'homme j mais
c'est normal
à voir robot chez moi ça ça m'aide
rennes je lui ai arraché ma chambre je
suis ni contre ni pour parce qu'il ya
des choses que ça peut être bien ça peut
aider les personnes les personnes soient
les handicapés ou lit ou les
les retraités comme ça oui ça fait du
bien si on fait des organes qui sont
artificiels ça c'est pas mal et il ya
beaucoup de débats aussi sur ce genre de
choses et je suis plutôt partagés ça
peut être bien comme ça peut être mal
parce qu'on sait jamais de la façon dont
un robot est créée par exemple ça peut
faire des catastrophes imaginons que les
laitiers à dist
ils craignent des robots pour enfin pour
les aider a mis à à nous attaquer à ce
serait un très bientôt
s'ils font des robots pour tous après
ben les humains il savions pas grand
chose en chine d'ici à des robots qui
sont serveurs basse apprend les places
des gens et ça fait perdre des emplois
et ça ça peut être très pratique pour
l'employeur d'équipé mon mais pour les
pour les salariés il ya un robot qui
s'appelle dégâts et grâce à évita teurs
y voit les émotions sur le visage de
l'enfant et il fait la même chose pour
les aider à progresser
j'aimerais pas avoir un robot metref je
préfère bad et je m'en réfère à voir à
une perse une vraie personne parce que
je pense que ça a comprend plus quand on
a des difficultés ça peut plus nous
aider car robot
un bond à présent des sujets que nous
développons à partir de lundi nous
reviendrons bien sûr sur cette loi
travail les discussions s'ouvrent le 3
mai à l'assemblée nationale alors que
les contestations progresse plusieurs
points importants pose toujours problème
notamment la surtaxation des cdd annoncé
par manuel valls et puis également dans
l'actualité la semaine prochaine la
journée nationale des mémoires de la
traite de l'esclavagé et de leurs
abolitions
plusieurs rendez vous sont prévus comme
chaque année à saint quentin en yvelines
exposition elle débats ou encore
rencontre d'ici là vous avez rendez-vous
ce week-end dimanche sur l'antenne de
nos confrères de radio sensations avec
nikola kirillovitch pour son hebdo
politiques invités dimanche à 18 heures
philippe esnol sénateur des yvelines
ancien maire de conflans il a quitté le
ps pour le parti radical gauche en 2013
et il se montre très critique envers son
ancienne famille politique écouter cet
extrait vous êtes éloigné du parti
socialiste en octobre 2013 sur un tweet
plus ou moins le tweet c'était juste
c'est le tweet en tout cas c'est ce qui
a manifesté votre envie de quitter le
parti socialiste vous parliez alors d'un
parti incapable de se faire élire l'eau
tellement et qui s'autorisent à donner à
tout le monde des leçons de morale en
prin de pathos sentimentale et
victimaire pour mieux servir leurs
intérêts personnels
qu'est ce qui s'est passé voilà je
démens c'est le dernier octobre 2013
quelques mois avant les élections ils
ont fait la mainmise des apparatchiks du
parti socialiste à l'époque sur le parti
sur la manière dont ils étaient dirigés
en particulier dans les yvelines avec
monsieur hamon et autres sbires qui
pouvait l'entourer et qui continuent
d'entourer et puis à ce moment là le
premier secrétaires c'était harlem désir
dont on a vu l'incompétence l incapacité
d aujourd'hui c'est le parti qui tient
on va dire toutes les sections et
finalement le mouvement n'est pas n'est
pas n'existe pas à traverser ses
adhérents ses journées oiseaux moins
d'adhérents parti socialiste et même la
qualité même
des rangs a baissé par rapport à ce que
j'ai pu connaître moi il ya 30 ans
l'intégralité de cet entretien dimanche
donc sur l'antenne de radio sensations
dans un instant sur tv fils vos idées
sorties et loisirs le 7-8 week-end de
préparer présenté cette semaine par
sephora namani c'est la fin de cette
édition du vendredi rendez vous lundi
aux horaires habituels pour un nouveau
journal d'ici là vous pouvez revoir nos
émissions et nos reportages en replay
sur le site internet très bon week-end